[Applause]
hey it's turning into an unwelcome
holiday tradition covid cases on the
rise yet again in many parts of the
country we already have a very stretched
Health Care system and this adds another
stress to an already stretched Health
Care System the biggest Hot Spot Ontario
where Wastewater testing data now
suggests cases have doubled from the
same time last year and in cities like
wealth cases have hit a 2-year Peak but
doctors believe that for most Canadians
those numbers shouldn't be too
concerning if you are young and healthy
there really is little to worry about
from a CO perspective that's ICU do
cuajo carang he's treated covid patients
since the start of the pandemic and
believes we're in a new covid era I do
think this is a time where this is the
time to be connected to have those
Christmas parties to connect with your
staff to be with family for family
members you may see who are elderly or
immuno compromised the same old advice
applies mask up stay home when you're
sick and keep up to date on vaccinations
but not just for covid shots for RSV and
influenza can also help stop serious
illness I'm just as concerned about the
upcoming influenza season for my
pediatric population and the ongoing RSV
season as I am about covid-19 and I
think that's true for uh most adults as
well the triple threat isn't expected to
overwhelm hospitals in Ontario but in
Quebec the health minister is warning
ERS could be full of sick patients with
limited staff due to public sector
strikes this going to be tough it's
going to be tough for the same reason
the combination of viruses and
everything doctors advice to stay up to
date on covid vaccinations seems to be
falling on deaf years with less than 20%
of Canadians 70 or older fully boosted